i study ants
in the desert in the tropical forest
and in my kitchen and in the hills
around silicon valley where i live
i've recently realized that ants are
using interactions differently
in different environments and that got
me thinking that we could learn from
this about other systems
like brains and data networks
that we engineer and even cancer
so what all these systems have in common
is that there's no central control
an ant colony consists of sterile female
workers
those are the ants you see walking
around and then one or more reproductive
females
who just lay the eggs they don't give
any instructions
even though they're called queens they
don't tell anybody what to do
so in an ant colony there's no one in
charge
and all systems like this without
central control are regulated
using very simple interactions ants
interact using
smell they smell with their antennae
and they interact with their antennae so
when one ant touches another with its
antennae
it can tell for example if the other ant
is a nest mate
and what task that other ant has been
doing
so here you see a lot of ants moving
around
and interacting in a lab arena that's
connected by tubes to two other arenas
so when one ant meets another it doesn't
matter which ant it meets
and they're actually not transmitting
any kind of complicated signal
or message all that matters to the ant
is the rate at which it meets other ants
and all of these interactions taken
together produce a network
so this is the network of the ants that
you just saw moving around in the arena
and it's this constantly shifting
network
that produces the behavior of the colony
like
whether all the ants are hiding inside
the nest or how many are going out to
forage
a brain actually works in the same way
but what's great about ants is that you
can see the whole network as it happens
there are more than twelve thousand
species of ants in every conceivable
environment
and they're using interactions
differently to meet different
environmental challenges
so one important environmental challenge
that every system has to deal with
is operating costs just what it takes to
run the system
and another environmental challenge is
resources finding them and collecting
them
in the desert operating costs are high
because water is scarce
and the seed eating ants that i study in
the desert have to spend
water to get water so an ant outside
foraging searching for seeds in the hot
sun just loses water into the air
but the colony gets its water by
metabolizing the fats out of the seeds
that they eat
so in this environment interactions are
used to activate foraging
an outgoing forager doesn't go out
unless it gets enough interactions with
returning foragers and what you see
are the returning foragers going into
the tunnel into the nest
and meeting outgoing foragers on their
way out this makes sense for the ant
colony because the more food there is
out there
the more quickly the foragers find it
the faster they come back and the more
foragers they send out
the system works to stay stopped unless
something positive happens so
interactions function to
activate foragers and we've been
studying the evolution of the system
first of all there's variation it turns
out that colonies are different
on dry days some colonies forage less so
colonies are different in how they
manage this trade-off
between spending water to search for
seeds and getting water back
in the form of seeds and we're trying to
understand
why some colonies forage less than
others by thinking about ants as neurons
using models from neuroscience so just
as a neuron
adds up its stimulation from other
neurons to decide whether to fire
an ant adds up its stimulation from
other ants to decide whether to forage
and what we're looking for is whether
there might be small differences among
colonies
and how many interactions each ant needs
before it's willing to go out and forage
because a colony like that would forage
less
and this raises an analogous question
about brains
we talk about the brain but of course
every brain is slightly different
and maybe there are some individuals or
some conditions in which
the electrical properties of neurons are
such that
they require more stimulus to fire
and that would lead to differences in
brain function
so in order to ask evolutionary
questions we need to know about
reproductive success
this is a map of the study site where i
have been tracking this population
of harvester ant colonies for 28 years
which is about as long as a colony lives
each symbol is a colony and the size of
the symbol is how many offspring it had
because we were able to use genetic
variation to match up
parent and offspring colonies that is to
figure out
which colonies were founded by a
daughter queen produced by which parent
colony
and this was amazing for me after all
these years to find out for example the
colony 154
whom i've known well for many years is a
great grandmother
here's her daughter colony here's her
granddaughter colony
and these are her great granddaughter
colonies and by doing this i was able to
learn
that offspring colonies resemble parent
colonies
in their decisions about which days are
so hot that they don't forage
and the offspring and parent colonies
live so far from each other that the
ants never meet
so the ants of the offspring colony
can't be learning this from the parent
colony
and so our next step is to look for the
genetic variation
underlying this resemblance
so then i was able to ask okay who's
doing better
over the time of the study and
especially in the past 10 years there's
been a very severe and deepening drought
in the southwestern u.s and it turns out
that the colonies that conserve water
that stay in when it's really hot
outside
and thus sacrifice getting as much food
as possible are the ones more likely to
have offspring colonies
so all this time i thought the colony
154 was a loser
because on really dry days there'd be
just this trickle of foraging
while the other colonies were out
foraging getting lots of food
but in fact colleen 154 is a huge
success she's a matriarch she's one of
the rare great grandmothers on the site
to my knowledge this is the first time
that we've been able to track
the ongoing evolution of collective
behavior
in a natural population of animals and
find out
what's actually working best
now the internet uses an algorithm to
regulate the flow
of data that's very similar to the one
that the harvester ants are using to
regulate the flow of foragers
and guess what we call this analogy
the internet is coming yeah
so data doesn't leave the source
computer unless it gets a signal that
there's enough bandwidth
for it to travel on in the early days of
the internet when operating costs were
really high
and it was really important not to lose
any data
then the system was set up for
interactions to activate
the flow of data it's interesting that
the ants are using an algorithm that's
so similar to one that we
recently invented but this is only one
of a handful of ant algorithms that we
know about
and ants have had 130 million years
to evolve a lot of good ones and i think
it's very likely
that some of the other 12 000 species
are going to have
interesting algorithms for data networks
that we haven't even thought of yet
so what happens when operating costs are
low
operating costs are low in the tropics
because it's very humid and it's easy
for the ants to be outside
walking around but the ants are so
abundant and diverse in the tropics
that there's a lot of competition
whatever resource one species is using
another species is likely to be using
that at the same time
so in this environment interactions are
used in the opposite way
the system keeps going unless something
negative happens and one species that i
study makes circuits in the trees of
foraging ants going from the nest to
food source and back just round and
round
unless something negative happens like
an interaction with ants of another
species so here's an example of ant
security in the middle there's an ant
plugging the nest entrance with its head
in response to interactions with another
species those are the little ones
running around with their abdomens up in
the air
but as soon as the threat is passed the
entrance is open again
and maybe there are situations in
computer security where operating costs
are low enough
that we could just block access
temporarily
in response to an immediate threat and
then open it again
instead of trying to build a permanent
firewall or fortress
so another environmental challenge that
all systems have to deal with
is resources finding and collecting them
and to do this ants solve the problem of
collective search
and this is a problem that's of great
interest right now in robotics because
we've understood that rather than
sending a single
sophisticated expensive robot out to
explore another planet or to search a
burning building
that instead it may be more effective to
get
a group of cheaper robots exchanging
only minimal information
and that's the way that ants do it so
the invasive argentine ad makes
expandable search networks
they're good at dealing with the main
problem of collective search
which is the trade-off between searching
very thoroughly
and covering a lot of ground and what
they do is when there are many ants in a
small space then each one can search
very thoroughly
because there'll be another ant nearby
searching over there
but when there are a few ants in a large
space
then they need to stretch out their
paths to cover more ground
i think that they use interactions to
assess density so when they're really
crowded they meet more often
and they search more thoroughly
different ant species
must use different algorithms because
they've evolved to deal
with different resources and it could be
really useful to know about this
and so we recently asked ants to solve
the collective search problem in the
extreme environment
of microgravity in the international
space station
when i first saw this picture i thought
oh no they've mounted the habitat
vertically
but then i realized that of course it
doesn't matter
so the idea here is that the ants are
working so hard to
hang on to the wall or the floor or
whatever you call it
that they're less likely to interact
and so the relationship between how
crowded they are and how often they meet
would be messed up
we're still analyzing the data i don't
have the results yet
but it would be interesting to know how
other species solve this problem
on in different environments on earth
and so we're setting up a program to
encourage kids around the world
to try this experiment with different
species it's very simple
it can be done with cheap materials and
that way we could make a
global map of ant collective
search algorithms and i think it's
pretty likely that the invasive species
the ones that come into our buildings
are going to be really good at this
because they're in your kitchen
because they're really good at finding
food and water
so the most familiar resource for ants
is a picnic and this is a clustered
resource
when there's one piece of fruit there's
likely to be another piece of fruit
nearby
and the ants that specialize on
clustered resources
use interactions for recruitment so when
one ant meets another or when it meets a
chemical deposited on the ground by
another
then it changes direction to follow in
the direction of the interaction
and that's how you get the trail of ants
sharing your picnic
now this is a place where i think we
might be able to learn something from
ants
about cancer i mean first it's obvious
that we could do a lot to prevent cancer
by not allowing people to spread around
or sell
the toxins that promote the evolution of
cancer in our bodies
but i don't think the ants can help us
much with this because ants never poison
their own colonies
but we might be able to learn something
from ants about treating cancer
there are many different kinds of cancer
each one originates in a particular part
of the body
and then some kinds of cancer will
spread or metastasize
to particular other tissues where they
must be getting resources that they need
so if you think from the perspective of
early metastatic cancer cells as they're
out searching around
for the resources that they need if
those resources are clustered
they're likely to use interactions for
recruitment
and if we can figure out how cancer
cells are recruiting then maybe we could
set
traps to catch them before they become
established
so ants are using interactions in
different ways in a huge variety of
environments
and we could learn from this about other
systems that operate without central
control
using only simple interactions ant
colonies have been performing
amazing feats for more than 130 million
years
we have a lot to learn from them thank
you